hello welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of e3 2015 and this is day one
would you believe I wouldn't believe it
because it seems like we've had two days
of incredible announcements from
software developers for publishers from
hardware manufacturers and one of those
hardware manufacturers corporeal form is
in front of us right now it's ridiculous
Angry Bird thank you so much for coming
on talking to us and I see you've got a
little pouch there I do have a little
time for a second well we'll talk about
it will easter egg here and a lot of
people social media going crazy about
what sony revealed yesterday you guys
had a really solid show and first thing
in the morning it's obviously always
hardest to go first but in terms of I
guess what's coming out this year yeah
it seems like there's a lot stuff
happening on xbox there's a lot of
exclusive games happening as well as it
was out of focus for you guys absolutely
I mean for us we have what we think is
the greatest games lineup in the history
of xbox and we've been working really
hard to kind of bring this together this
particular year and we know people have
been waiting for things like halo 5 know
people waiting for Gears of War to come
back we also have tomb raider coming
exclusively this holiday we have a new
fable we have forza motorsport 6 we have
gigantic we have seven with rare replay
as well we have seven exclusive games
all coming this holiday frankly we've
never had that type of lineup ever
before and so for us we just how do we
fit it all into one briefing and frankly
you saw we had a lot of games of branch
Isis people want to see that we're even
saving to gamescom because we just ran
out of time yeah you're right scalebound
wasn't here at the guys from remedy I
know yes i said i have had to sit on a
scale bound crackdown quantum break even
some other surprises we're gonna save
those for games commons to kind of shift
our focus to 2016 but for e3 for us it's
really about the 2015 games lineup and
all the big exclusives are bringing this
holiday and let's talk about your big
cheese where we're looking at it right
now halo 5 Guardians obviously hotly
anticipated and the sort of the main
franchise when it comes to Xbox what
people think about I was watching his
presentation at a time to felt like what
you guys were doing was out our destiny
death
Denis it sort of felt like that yeah
that like co-op online experience that I
guess we sort of now associate with
destiny because that's what people
who've been playing recently and what do
you think is the core focus for halo
because obviously it's expanded so big
yeah so many different types of game
modes and when you're showing that game
off what do you really want to sort of
slow it's definitely the most ambitious
halo title 343 has ever gone off to make
and you know people i think expected us
to show campaign for the first time but
to be able to reveal that you can play
both as Spartan Locke also play as
master chief the fact that it is four
player co-op but it's true drop in drop
out four player co-op at any moment in
time you can instantly drop in if a
friend comes in for 10 minutes and drops
out there instantly replaced by a I the
game the campaign design is made for
that you know this whole sort of Hunter
versus hunted sort of tension we've been
playing up between chief and lock and
we're going to reveal more of that as we
get closer to kind of getting deeper
into the story and then we showed you
know people know we're bringing the
traditional halo multiplayer with the
arena style more competitive eSports
focus but the big new innovation the big
new hottest is war zone and so the team
really invested a lot of multiplayer
with this release and four times bigger
than any other halo map ever made the
fact they're gonna have massive 12 v12
blue team versus red team you know
they're going to be tons of weapons tons
the vehicle there's AI in there i mean
it's just these massive scale
multiplayer you we've never seen this
before from halo and so a lot of
innovation we're really excited about
yeah it looks very exciting and a lot of
people on CASEVAC amor freaking out I
bet I can't wait to get their hands on
it and I want to talk to about rare for
a little bit because it seemed for a
while there that Microsoft wasn't really
doing right by what rare was and this
year very much seems like you've sort of
you know in the way that Sony have taken
some franchises and said you okay you
know what you can have it and with this
rare collection you're taking 30 of the
best rare games and some some very
popular ones on there goldeneye for
instances in there and what was this was
this something you felt like you needed
to do with rare you know i was able to
work with rare from the original when
they first pitch us the concept and it's
been a labor of love for them i mean
this is their 30th anniversary and it's
very rare to have a developer that has
that type of rich heritage and you know
they had hundreds and hundreds of games
and we went through the whole catalog
and you know really lovingly thought
about how do we take this collection
from you know battletoads to blast corps
to jet pack perfect perfect dark I'm an
old r c pro-am fan of an old-school
arcade nicely viva pinata and there
somewhere yes you did and so you know
the n64 conquer banjos and I mean like
it's 30 like great games and probably
some games you never you maybe be even
played and so to be able to take that
30-year history to bring it together in
a collection that people can play and
we're delivering it 30 games for thirty
dollars I think it's a great value the
other thing we said nobody ever releases
video games during the summer like why
not we're out of school you know what we
setting we see people a lot people on
xbox live so the the first week of
August times the games come we're
releasing the title and so will give
gamers some you know 30 new games to
play and 10,000 gamerscore points to oh
really walking oh yeah so you are
kidding me about 30 bucks for 10,000
gamer maybe the best ROI on him right or
ever that's even better than that avatar
game I only bought for the points let's
talk about VR enero for a second
obviously and you guys were involved in
what oculus showed off last week and
enhancing a partnership with steam as
well this time around and of course
hololens a very good presentation
Microsoft are obviously throwing in with
their own thing with morpheus you guys
seem to be spreading the risk a little
bit where do you think Microsoft lies
when it comes to this technology because
at the moment it seems like you've got
fingers in a couple of pies sure I mean
we're really excited about what's
happening with VR and mixed reality and
all that so for us we we see this as
early days this is pioneering really a
lot of innovation is happening I don't
think people quite know you know exactly
how this is all going to turn out we
want to support and give consumers as
much choice as possible we don't want to
bet on only one technology one solution
right now and frankly the beauty of
building on the windows 10
infrastructure is that whether it's on
Xbox one whether it's hololens whether
it's working with folks like oculus or
valve you know we stream xbox one games
to your Windows 10 PC
oculus rift is another great display for
that will be working with valve and
their be our solution on that we're
bundling the xbox one controller with
every oculus rift so just supporting VR
and mixed reality in multiple different
ways and then you saw with what we're
doing with hololens is that we're
innovating in that world where we're
taking your real world environment and
mixing that with you know with
holographic elements and I think
minecraft was a great example of kind of
seeing that come to life and Ricky that
was one of my favorite parts of the
brain it was it was probably one of the
best versions of selling that type of
technology to people already showing
them because the problem with like we
have a massive um in terms of video
coverage here on gamespot trying to show
people that cool vrs yeah I so for a
presentation to the way you guys have
shot this I think really helped have one
piece of technology we didn't see at all
mentioned was connect though obviously
there's a Kinect lyst version of xbox
and one now are you guys done with
Kinect we are we are absolutely
continuous aboard connect but we're
innovating with Kinect in a different
way I mean we're bringing a lot more
features alive so we announced the new
xbox one experience yeah that will
include Cortana so you able to have
voice commands building more
intelligence into that but we really
want connect to be a choice for
customers for me i love it i turn my
xbox no I'm with gonna i use it for
entertainment I used it to do
screenshots and you know and all that I
like to build have a hands-on controller
and use voice commands but frankly a lot
of people also have that one a better
value and don't want to have to pay for
it so we're not going to force people to
do that we give people the choice and so
we're continuing support connect where
it makes sense cool and speaking of
controllers what's this up thing you got
here yes i thought i'm guessing anyway
it is by the way our new elite wireless
this is the actual case that it comes in
ice so you know we really care a lot
about our controllers spent a lot of
time on the xbox one controller but we
had you drop a hundred and fifty bucks
on a controller at least as you get is a
case fair enough fair enough yes but we
have a lot of pro gamers that play on
xbox one today and we worked with them
and got a lot of their feedback on
designing what we think is the best
controller frankly that we've ever made
and so even before you get in the
functionality just how beautiful the
chrome finish I mean just how beautiful
this controller looks it's very it's
like we call it hold it give it a feel
oh yeah it's super son oh I like these
guys yeah
so we've got the paddles in the back
these are all mapped to the ABX y
buttons you can pull them out you can
customize fully customizable for you
know what programmers told us is that we
we have typically loser triggers for
things like Forza but yes you're playing
halo and you want the hairpin like not
just with a flick flick of a switch I
was my a super clicky yeah so faster oh
yeah faster shooting with the hairpin
triggers that was actually because I'm a
massive car game fan and that in 42
having that ability to do that was
fantastic but it is a bit of an issue
when you're running and then you can
customize a program every single button
and then making the d-pad even better
but if you said hey I wanted the
traditional d-pad you simply take this
out and then you put this in it's just a
magnetic drop in wow you want to just
get a different size all of this is
swappable you say FPS you want a taller
one hears you want a rounder one here I
mean want old ones on the left really
know people like that and I'm no eSports
I kind so the nice thing is you can
customize at all you can have hundreds
of different profiles you can even in
Game switch from one pile profile to the
other alone so it's a pretty exciting
device i am i'm super selfish that's
when I play a little bit and you're
right it is the price of two controllers
but you get you get a true pro
controller and it's an elite product
that we're really excited about
excellent so when is this actually gonna
be available we're taking pre-orders now
but it launches this holiday awesome and
it does come with the case yeah I got a
bunch more questions absolutely top
conference at yeah but also I just want
to ask your opinion at Sony yesterday
had a pretty stellar conference of their
own obviously showing off and a bunch of
Game people were very excited about the
Last Guardian and seeing final fantasy
in there as well and then Shenmue are
those projects that you think you might
see on next on Microsoft platforms as
well well some of them that are owned by
Sony we would expect not yeah but you
know you're right and they had a great
show and you know if we watch their
briefing every year and it's great to
kind of come to e3 and everyone sort of
shows all their games and all the new
announcements and there's a lot of fan
favorites and I think they did a great
job you know at the end we we do do a
little bit of a kind of a geeky
scorecard or we sort of look at you know
how many games do we show how many
exclusive jewelry show how do we kind of
stack up and you know we both showed 20
what citroen we both showed the same
amount of games will show 24 games in
every
thing we both showed 11 exclusive titles
we showed 7 exclusives that are coming
this holiday and so he actually didn't
show any that we saw that we could they
confirmed this year yeah I think that
was the biggest difference they showed a
lot of games and it's a fan favorite
since the games i'm looking forward to
playing as well on their platforms but
for us we think the big difference is
we're delivering the big exclusive games
this year and we'll talk more about 2016
as we kind of move into gas common and
they're going forward and what are the
interesting things from your conference
was the idea that there are actually
quite a lot of xbox 360 owners who might
end of transition to the Xbox one and do
you think that these are folks who have
sort of gone to the dark side are these
folks who have picked up PlayStation 4's
or are there actually like latent 360
owners who just haven't been on the next
generation yeah we look at pretty
closely I mean what we know is that
today there's tens of millions of xbox
360 owners what we do go out and talk to
them they basically tell us they've been
waiting for the time and the reason to
migrate and a lot of people have been
waiting for the next halo a lot of
people have been waiting for Gears a lot
of people waiting for backwards
compatibility and so we think having all
that coming this holiday we expect we're
going to see a massive migration and we
expect millions of xbox 360 owners to
migrate it moved xbox one and we see the
majority of people to buy an xbox one
today own an xbox 360 so our fan base
has stayed very loyal and frankly
they're waiting for those new releases
to come this year and backward
compatibility would not underestimate
how big that will be for them and
getting them to move yeah mi earn
another thing you guys showed off was
that you guys are going to be stepping
your toe into the already access world
and yes having games that you know it's
it's been a sort of a tough road for
steam but it's actually proved to be
when it works it works really well can
you just talk about how that works and
how you guys are going to be able to
police that system because I kind of an
issue that valve of had there steams
done some great work here with early
access and as we've been working with
the independent developers as part of
our ID at Xbox program you know one of
the things we were consistently from
them is hey we want to be able to have
something like early access we can let
people play these games early but one of
the learnings we learn is that we want
to do this in the right way when we will
bring it to the console so our program
is called game preview it's officially
launched here
III and so the way we're doing is we're
curating it so it's not going to be wild
west just any possible game we're going
to take games that we think fit in that
model that are on a path to actual true
release every single game comes with the
trials you get to try the game before
you buy it so we're really thinking
about the customer experience first and
putting our fans first in this way we're
excited so we've got Dean Hall it's
really sort of the father of this this
early access bringing things like Daisy
bringing his new eye on a project to
game preview we have the folks bringing
a number of other titles and so we've
got both elite dangerous and the long
piece of sighs my long day new titles
available today up in game preview and
so hopefully your people go check them
out and and then you know provide
feedback to the developers much like
they do on the pc today cool exciting
stuff happening over at Microsoft iron
thank you so much for your time today I
got one more question because upstairs i
was asking people a bunch of well what
would if you had the chance to ask our
question what would you ask what's going
on with this steven spielberg halo thing
Steven Spielberg is a huge fan in fact
he's coming to e3 on thursday i
understand he comes every year we have a
great partnership with them at this
point we're not telling people what
we're doing okay that you know the
partnership continues and stay tuned all
right he's probably busy with that whole
you know dinosaur thing you can decide
whatever it was a busier world in just
video games yeah sure the point I'm Gary
tuck you stop still coming on but enjoy
the rest of your show thank you same
time with us I'm thank you for watching
we are still live here on the gamespot
stage we got a bunch more appts up I've
only actually got one left but it's a
fantastic series 1 i've been a fan of
since back in the days in 1994 I feel
9898 i think is when I faith my first
rainbow six I'll be back in a couple of
minutes with siege stay tuned